hi Jojo this is Jojo in 2019 hey Mike
I'm calling from five years ago hey it's
you I mean me um has it been five years
hi Ashley
this is your 18 year old self I wanted
to call and ask you if you finally
learned how to love yourself if you're
finally healed from all the pain nothing
then I've brought you in your life did
you finish school
did you like Design School did you get a
job you fall in love again
and did you get all those tattoos okay
bye
hopefully I'll be able to say yes always
because you're so used conversating with
other people rather than your own self
so I'm really trying to learn how to
like Center in on my own self and
embrace myself which is why I asked my
future self but she finally learned how
to love herself just really getting
comfortable for talking to me yeah
Enrique I hope everything's going well
one important thing is that hope you
have the courage to finally come out to
your parents and your family I know
right now it's hard you don't see
yourself I don't see myself doing it
right now but like hopefully in the
future you're able to and you know
and they're okay with it and everything
yeah that's it
by feels good like it gives me a reason
to actually like one day actually be
able to tell my parents and come out to
my sense yeah and it felt good you know
a little weird but it felt good to be
able to say especially to other people
like yeah I don't really talk I mean
she's the only one that really knows and
my other friends like my close friends
but that's it for it to be recorded and
everything is kind of like a little
weird but hey hey Mike I'm calling from
five years ago and Gobbo Park in San
Diego you're here with your lovely wife
and daughter on your last vacation
before she heads off to college you're
gonna be getting this five years from
now so hopefully by then you'll remember
what a great time it was how you enjoyed
spending that time with her before she
left
important a place for you yeah so do
that again it's really worth
I welcome the opportunity to do this it
was her dirt is safe and when I was
doing it in my head pretty easily there
hey that's me from the past
I wanna ask you remember to keep your
girlfriend's flowers every day do you
remember that like years ago you had
this idea I hope that you still do that
if not please go and search some flowers
three quickly and give her a lot a lot a
lot of flowers so bye
and the flower and the flower oh yeah so
you actually give her a flower every day
yeah how long have you been doing that
for if he forgets that he gives me to
the next thing a great time in college
and study a lot and have a great job
when you grow up I hope you have a great
life buddy hi Kareem how are you today
good nice all right so I was just
calling you to tell you the like just go
to the bakery like something real close
from you and get something with
chocolate like right now that make you
happy all right so have a nice day have
fun right I'm like excited actually to
go out and like hear it Craig do so now
and go and get something with chocolate
on high Jojo this is Jojo in 2019 and
I'm calling to remind you
that you were standing in the middle of
Balboa Park on a sunny day 60 degrees
hanging out with your grandmother who's
91 and your beautiful wife two very
important people in your life so I want
you to remember in the future when you
listen to this message on those days
when you feel like the world isn't a
beautiful place that it is because of
the people that are in your life okay
talk to you later
have a good day right my voice and
Hannah hey it's you I mean me um has it
been five years that seems like a long
time I guess it won't be in college
anymore that's crazy
I wonder where we'll be I mean it's
still you it's not a stranger I hope you
recognize me yeah I hope I recognize you
hmm well I'll be weird alright see you
then I guess it's weird to think about
five years seems like a really long time
to me but I guess it's just because I'm
young so I don't know how old are you
I'm 18
well I'm 19 now I just turned 19 Oh what
my mailbox is full
hi Kristina it's Kristina from the past
I have time travel to tell you that I
hope you have a garden and that it's
full of red peppers tomatoes and lemons
because you love that and also I hope
you have your own staffing company by
now and I hope you're killing it
okay love you bye it's good it's good
it feels great not to perform for
someone else other than you like Gosling
you earlier it's so easy to answer that
question in a job interview but it's
more difficult to do it for you so I'm
glad I took that time and reflected and
an actual license you know what we do
think of that just watching something
grow is inspiring to me and I want to
live a more sustainable life in the
future like more low waste kind of thing
I don't think I'll ever be zero waste
but you know that's what I strive for
and also I want to share with people so
yeah I just wanted to know if you guys
ever went to New York or ever got the
dogs we wanted you know maybe a corgi
maybe a
what colleges we get into what kind of
jobs we get into after we get out of the
military you know
Gateway's okay Mary you know be
interesting to find out what happens in
five years
hopefully I grow a little bit taller you
know so I'm not so short experienced I
love everywhere we go yeah I hope so
that's what I hope for us in fighting
[Music]
hello Ben this is you at 27 this is a
message for you at 32 we are standing in
Balboa Park right now it's the first
time you've gone to Cali five years from
now I plan on coming out here every year
until that so third at 32 at this exact
moment we will be standing here again
with our kids
and a ring on your finger yes ma'am
all right just letting you know take it
easy hey Ken this is you from five years
ago
listen I know five five years ago you
weren't going through the best times of
your life everything going on with
family friends work and loved ones but
listen don't let anything stop you from
continuing on chasing your dreams
whatever happens happens if you get back
with that special someone you get back
with that special someone if you fix
those things those things are fixed but
if things don't work out and then
probably meant meant to be then never
forget where you came from who helped
you along the way and don't forget about
number one as yourself I believe in you
as I believe you should believe in
yourself and I love you bye see you in
five years I felt really good because
like I said I've been going through a
lot of things in the past year and a
half and honestly not everyone that I
know knows exactly what I want to hear
or what to say to me and that's
basically what I feel I want to hear and
feel from them but I know they can't
because they're not me they don't know
what's going on in my head what's going
on in my life everyone needs to hear
what they want to hear from themselves
if they can't hear from the
they love most so this is me
know that life has a way of working
itself out even if you don't know
what's going on
to know that nothing is permanent
know that it's all relative and
things are constantly changing you don't
have to have it figured out right now
make it easy
give yourself the same compassion that
you
to someone
I mean I think I'm just going through a
hard time
it just becomes personal when you say it
out loud
I don't know like rila tears aren't bad
they just hey Katie its you five years
in the past year in Balboa Park the
evolving conference for tossa eating a
sandwich from the grocery store and a
young woman asked if she could record me
leaving you a voicemail for posterity
and YouTube
I hope the planets not dead yet hope
things are good
alright fight I don't really know what I
want for myself or the future in five
years I hope we're in a better place
than we right now though hey guys I hope
you enjoyed watching this episode I
thought it was a pretty cool project to
film because in five years I plan to
find everyone and record them listening
to the voicemail on camera so that I'll
be part two and I know five years is a
long time but I hope you guys will still
be around for that in the meantime I'll
see you guys next week
[Music]
you